a local teenager making a remarkable
recovery after being sickened by the
johnson and johnson coronavirus vaccine
that is 18 year old emma burkey she's
one of six women across the country who
became severely ill after getting the
medicine the coral academy senior
suffered blood clots to her brain well
now she's back home here in las vegas
after several surgeries she'd been in
california for a long time and now she's
learning to walk again
friends and family say she is a living
miracle
different parts of her body is
functioning well different sides of her
body
and then other parts are still very slow
to come back i think every step counts
there's really no shortcuts in the
journey of recovery
that's family friend and pastor hayden
ratner he says even in the midst of her
battle right now emma's personality is
still shining through
she recently just reached out to my wife
and just said i can't wait to babysit
again at a high level right and so those
things are on her heart
emma's recovery certainly has been long
and it's been expensive if you would
like to help the family with their
medical bills they have a gofundme page
it's linked on our website
eightnewsnow.com and that's where they
also give a lot of updates on emma's
recovery they do that almost once a week
maybe every two weeks so you can see how
emma is doing so she's so strong such a
fighter yeah